Hitori Goto, a first-year junior high school student
, I sometimes wonder if it's okay to stay like this, but
I've had days like a shadowy character, and if you
're a
fund, you're a person like me, but maybe you can
shine.
We performed at
the school festival and didn't even make a single friend in the first place It
's okay to go to the live house right away I'll be
playing the bass, so the blood transfusion is rock
and roll so we have to work
harder  The people of the world
thought I wasn't interested in myself, but I'm all alone
Bocchi-chan is such a kind person who
has been watching over me for a long time and has called out to
me.  I have a feeling
Bocce the Rock will start airing in October That's Ochi-
chan, I'm
sorry
I want to take a break in a dark and cramped place, but I take a break
quickly